[Music]
there is no way Disney ever envisioned
James Corden as valve but you know what
he was amazing stopping traffic on last
night's Late Late Show belting out a
montage of songs from Beauty and the
Beast with some of the stars from the
movie god I love that meanwhile our
Carly Steele just found out some
surprising new things about the real
Belle Emma Watson I think people are
surprised in real life that I'm probably
sillier than I am it's fine you know um
under-promise over-deliver yes people
think I'm super serious no we love the
serious Emma who does things like hide
books in the New York City subway to
promote literacy love random acts of
kindness but Emma let loose is Belle in
the new live action version of Beauty
and the Beast with a voice even she
didn't know she had daunting was it you
heard you had to say I was convinced I
was like Flora's Foster Jenkins it tooks
some some conversations with myself in
the mirror she mornings you know get it
together Wilson but really the best
thing about Emma
she's a friend for life the Harry Potter
alum has a group chat going with her
former co-stars and they're all really
supportive of her new movie not Lewis
and she Bolton came to screen we just
had in LA it's kinda like Pokemon I'm
trying to catch them all right now
[Music]
you